the names of the tens fot are ker
meaning Crown HMA meaning wisdom Bina
understanding loving kindness G power or
judgment tiit Beauty n Triumph or
endurance hod Majesty yod foundation and
malut Kingdom that last SP malut is very
important not only for being identified
with this world in a sense or at least
the the the stage for this world but
also for being identified with the the
had been a part of Jewish thought for a
long time and denoted God's presence in
the world the is the last SPH which is
present in the world in other words the
is the divine feminine identified as
God's presence in the world and
identical to the last SP of malut so
this is the Divine structure in
theosophical cabala